the grammy-nominated rapper his name is
gunna is trying to bridge the divide
between the lifestyle he now enjoys and
the way he lived growing up for our
series of more perfect union on what
unites us as americans there's a lot of
stuff mark straussman shows us how gunna
is bringing a spirit of generosity to a
place he knows very well
atlanta's ronald mcnair middle school
teaches about struggle
lots of kids come from single parent
homes they're old enough to realize what
families like theirs live without
they're mad
and they're not mad at us they're just
mad at the situation that they just left
principal john madden told us every
student here qualifies for free or
assisted meals hunger is a challenge
clothing clothing
resources you have a number of families
barely hanging on we have over 900
students and there's over 900 struggles
and challenges
and we have to we have to deal with that
right next to the gym this space softens
the stress
it opened this fall gunna's drip closet
stocked with groceries snacks new
sneakers and clothes all free you heard
a gunner
i have heard a gun through my um my
children okay
yeah i did hear a gun because kids will
keep you connected almost definitely yes
you have to stay connected to middle
school gonna is a grammy-nominated
atlanta rapper when his mother told him
never forget where you come from he
listened i was a cool kid oh you were
right
that cool kid was born sergio kitchens
and eventually went to mcnair middle
school was money tight we weren't doing
no splurge it was a struggle
for sure you see yourself and some of
these kids most definitely
gunna is now 28 but he tricked out this
store as though he was 14 again
everything that's in here all of these
are like
some of my go-to's so you were on top of
the swiss rolls for sure
everything in here restocked weekly he
pays for all of it i like air jordans
air jordan yeah put them a whole grocery
store now just fill it up oh yeah
make sure they are closed shoes though
you got jeans you got sneakers in there
why was that important to you that's
stuff i wanted when i was a kid like
that
i know like i couldn't just go to my mom
and ask for but mcnair's kids and
parents can go to gunna's closet they
provided a bag and whatever they fit in
the bag it's theirs they go home with
they go home with for free
like jasmine king's two girls dy honesty
an eighth grader and janila a sixth
grader yeah i got this sweater do the
kids see it as a cool thing yes they do
yeah it's not like oh your mom must be
poor what is it it's a positive thing
and they got the vans it is to their
mother this was her family's second trip
to the closet groceries for their table
clothes on her daughters that was the
first thing that she wanted yeah this is
my favorite color i was shocked i really
was shocked and the price is right right
right
it's absolutely right
what kind of a difference did that make
for you a huge difference because it
took a load off of my shoulders when i
walked into the store to know that i had
that burden lifted for a couple of weeks
you could breathe easier yes you're
absolutely right gunna's goal all along
you know how many moms like at home like
struggle but don't ask so you just gotta
just find it in your heart to just try
to give back and just help others
especially if you can what are you
getting out of this this what you say
you gonna do
me being a man of my word me just
being solid that's what i did it for
gunna's drip closet also offers free
life lessons live up to your promises
and listen to your mother
for cbs mornings mark strassman in
atlanta
love everything about gonna love the
closet i love his philosophy and i love
what he's trying to do and is doing yeah
i love when the little girl said no you
don't feel ashamed going there
he's made that very cool yeah
one thing i can't respect is a rapper
that brags about his material items and
never gives back so shout out to gunner
for giving back to communities that he's
familiar with yeah that is absolutely
awesome reach